We have built a sensor platform
for mobile devices that
uses vision to track motion,
recognize faces, and scan
the surroundings in 3D.
My name is Nikolai,
and in this episode,
we will talk about the
depth perception concepts
and tools available
for you to get started.
With the 3D depth
sensor, you can
scan the space
that surrounds you,
and use the data to build
models of your reality.
If you need to fit a
new TV on your wall,
or place a virtual
castle on the floor,
or see how much ice cream
you can fit in that freezer,
you may want to
continue watching.
Depth perception can
create static models
of the surroundings
as you scan them.
If you combine depth perception
with motion tracking,
you get the power to
have virtual objects
coexist with physical objects
right in front of you.
This can be used to detect
surfaces, obstacles,
or shapes of objects.
Let's say we wanted to simulate
a gecko walking on the ceiling.
We would use depth
perception to detect
the surface of the ceiling, and
use motion tracking to follow
the gecko around the house.
You won't need to know
all the details of how
depth sensors work, but
it's helpful to have
a general understanding to
make the best use of them.
There are several
technologies available,
which we will mention
three major ones.
First, we have
structured light systems.
They send out an
infrared dot pattern
to illuminate the contours
of the environment.
The device that measure
the size of the dots,
the larger the dot gets,
the further away it is.
Second, time-of-flight systems
use specialized sensors
to measure depth,
based on the time
it takes to transmit
an infrared beam
and capture its reflection.
At short distances,
it only takes
the light a few nanoseconds, or
a few billionths of a second,
to travel back and forth.
Third, there are
stereo systems, which
captures the scene
with two cameras that
are a short distance
apart, and infer depth
from using triangulation.
Does that sound complicated?
Well, this is very much
how human eyes work.
Two eyes, or cameras
for that matter, that
are able to see the same scene,
but from slightly different
angles, enables the viewer
to gain a perception of depth
using trigonometry.
The infrared-based
depth sensors,
such as structured light or
time-of-flight based systems,
have the benefit of working
particularly well indoors,
in low light and
where there isn't
any textures on the walls.
On the other hand,
infrared light
is less reliable
in direct sunlight
and on very dark surfaces, which
tend to absorb infrared light,
because it reduces the amount
of depth data you will acquire.
The sensors in Project
Tango are currently
optimized to scan room size
and static environments,
which makes it well
suited for detecting
surfaces, large objects,
like walls, doors, tables,
and chairs.
Other requirements to bear in
mind as you design your program
is the need for resolution,
range, and speed.
Resolution determines how
much detail you can capture.
Range, how close or far
you can be to an object.
And speed is how fast you
can capture the motion.
Project Tango returns depth
data as a point cloud.
It is the raw representation
of what the sensor detects.
You can use Project
Tango Explorer
to see what data looks like
in the point cloud mode.
Each of the displaced dots is
associated with a precision
and a distance to the device.
As you move around,
Explorer applies
motion tracking to combine
multiple point clouds into one.
The raw data is great for
calculating floor height,
distances to nearby objects,
or to find surfaces.
If you instead want to create
complete 3D models, or images,
you can use an app like
Project Tango Constructor.
Let's have a look
at how that works.
As you scan an area with
Constructor, the app combines
depth data with colored
images from the camera,
while you can watch the 3D
model of the surroundings
as it's being built. When
you're done scanning the area,
the constructor can export a
file of the generated 3D models
to the SD card.
From there, the
file can be imported
by other apps or games.
If you want to test drive a
micro version of the Mars Rover
in a sandbox, we
could use Constructor
to create 3D models of the
hills and valleys in the sand,
export the data, and
then build an app that
uses the exported data as
the surface for the Rover.
Project Tango is all about
connecting the virtual
with the physical experience.
And the depth sensor literally
brings the physical world
into the virtual
world, so you can
build virtual biology
experiments or Mars Rover
simulators.
Visit our Google Plus community,
and join us in our journey.
We are excited to see what you
will build with Project Tango.
[MUSIC PLAYING]